my name is Theriot I'm from Arab who are
global technology consulting company and
I'm on the infrastructure and Urban
Development Agenda Council the columns
that we face is how to get cities on the
global agenda because in the next 40
years the number of people living in
cities are going to be the same as the
growth over the last 4,000 years so if
you can think of every opera house every
metro system every sewage works every
hospital in the world then we've got to
build as many again in the next 40 years
as we have done in the last 4,000 that's
quite a challenge of course we've got to
do it far more sustainably zero or low
energy and carbon and we're going
through a recession so if every one of
those the problem the challenge it's
tougher so we've got to get smarter and
we're going to get smarter at delivering
Urban Development and the infrastructure
that under pendant in a far more organic
and with the grain of the planet then
cutting across it